roberto saviano la mafia et salvini
veulent votre mort ça prouve au moins
que vous êtes quelqu'un de bien
les français vous connaissent par vos
livres et par la série gomorra mais pour
ceux qui ne vous connaîtraient pas
encore on regarde c'était la première
fois qu'on a entendu parler de vous ici
en 2007 magnéto serge nous souhaitions
le rencontrer à naples trop dangereux
pour lui c'est à rome que roberto
saviano nous a donné rendez vous pour
une brève promenade dans un jardin
public entouré de ses gardes du corps
âgé de 28 ans cet écrivain napolitain a
osé défier la camorra la puissante mafia
locale dans son livre une enquête qui a
duré six ans il raconte en détail sa
mainmise sur la ville et surtout il
donne les noms des chefs de clans qui
depuis ont juré de l'assassiner combien
je vis avec lise et de la motion d'abord
parce que j'ai grandi sur un territoire
où des dizaines de personnes que je
connaissais ont été abattus comme je
l'écris dans mon livre le premier mort
par balle ce que j'ai vu j'avais 12 ans
j'ai grandi sur un territoire où il y
avait quatre manches argent
son territoire c'est naples ces
quartiers pauvres ces règlements de
compte sa mafia omniprésente du trafic
du ciment à celui de la cocaïne un monde
parallèle qui a résisté à tous les
assauts de l'état italien pour le
démanteler
je le dis sans crainte leur fausse c'est
une force capitaliste parce que cette
mafia la camorra évolue sans cesse parce
que la concurrence à l'intérieur et sans
pitié mais la concurrence est aussi les
tribunaux les forces de police la police
arrive à des morguiers enclos lorsque
celui ci est faible et en l'éliminant ou
créé un espace pour un nouveau club
roberto saviano n'a pas renoncé et
écrire sur la camorra à rome sa maison
d'édition lui a aménagé un bureau bien à
l'abri dans ses sous-sols ou ses gardes
du corps peuvent surveiller l'unique
entrée
je reconnais que souvent le matin je me
réveille en maudissant ce que j'ai fait
mais je le referais 300 x men et chasse
que c'était nécessaire d'écrire tout
cela je lis parfois des moments très
difficiles
ça serait stupide de le nier son livre
s'appelle gomorra comme gomorrhe la cité
de l'ancien testament que dieu détruisit
par le feu à cause de ces péchés naples
gomorrhe des temps modernes la cité du
mâle selon roberto saviano
alors roberto saviano vous avez
découvert que la mafia pouvait être
embarrassée par la littérature c'est
incroyable
oui c'est vrai
évitez la mafia a peur de la lumière
savent très bien qui dit à la police les
enquêtes des juges des tribunaux
ouais c'est que les homicides enfin
seulement l'objet les articles de la
presse rien de commencer
par contre ça va faire peur des yeux et
des oreilles de l'électeur
les spectateurs alors la mafia veut vous
tuer et c'est une information qui est
validée par de nombreux mafieux
repenti qui collaborent avec la justice
depuis 12 ans vous aviez 26 ans à
l'époque vous vivez sous protection
policière entre deux planque jamais sans
vos gardes du corps vous dites je suis
complètement paranoïaque je suis brisé
en petits morceaux on ne va pas tuer
mais on ne m'a pas laissé vivant non
plus estrun eswars
oui c'est 10 heures
lorsque les premières menaces me sont
arrivés qu'une telle information ni
c'était plutôt des informations
c'est comme si on me prévenait c'est
quoi ces coûts c'est à dire bien moment
donné on est obligé de se justifier
d'être vivant
on aurait dû tout de suite il ya dix ans
n'est ce pas comment ça se fait que tu
es toujours en vie
alors tu n'es pas dangereux
ce n'est qu'une mise en scène pour
vendre des livres manny ellie
brissonneau que seul on est forcément
biladi mais ce n'est peut-être pas noble
de le dire mais je crois que mes livres
sont ma vengeance est-ce qu'en france il
y à la mafia j'ai ouï les des motos
forte et les très fortes opus
mais la culture je sais pas pourquoi
dans la culture française
cette perception
après la deuxième guerre mondiale
fonctionne à marseille peut-être on a
fait attention à marseille
s'est qualifié d organisation mafieuse
françaises sont à
laquelle il suffit de penser que tout la
cocaïne qui arrivent en france ou
d'amérique à part
elle arrive en afrique
ensuite ce sont les corses qui la porte
en france et la mafia corse est très
forte peut-être parce qu'en france il
n'y a pas de sens donc a pas de mafia
c'est peut-être ça aussi douze
interventions c'est une bonne
observation ce tuning on remarque les je
m'assigne je voudrais chamonix que le
nombre de morts à marseille a dépassé le
lendemain matin et le nombre de morts à
naples est plus important que le nombre
de morts dans la bande de gaza les
atomes à tous tout à fait et si c'était
à refaire tout ça est ce que vous le
referiez
correspondre manier la chorale je
réponds pas de façon courageuse mais je
ne le referais pas vous êtes devenu un
héros est un héros moderne vous êtes
notre héros vous voulez venger les morts
de la mafia c'est ça l'histoire non
grasses beurre élimine définitivement
merci de m'avoir appelé héros
et pour une certaine partie des gens de
mon pays je ne suis pas du tout un héros
alors comment à votre premier livre a
été traduit en 50 langues
il s'est vendu à une dizaine de millions
d'exemplaires dans le monde avant d'être
adapté au cinéma au théâtre et
évidemment en séries télévisées alors
silvio berlusconi vous accuse de donner
une mauvaise image de l'italie
c'est nous y est maudit effectivement ce
n'est pas le seul nous ta vie une très
vieille accusation lorsqu'on parle de
mafia eh bien on est en train de
commencer de faire la notion de la
culture mafieuse c'est donc si on me
disait
imagine une chambre dans le noir dans
laquelle je rentre et si j'ai lu à la
lumière et on voit un cadavre à la
louche et c'est la faute à la lumière
c'est ce qu'on me dit alors après le
succès de gomorra vous avez publié extra
pur un livre consacré à l'économie de la
cocaïne c'est un marché qui pèse quand
même 300 milliards de dollars
après la mafia sicilienne vous êtes mis
à dos les cartels mexicains
et aujourd'hui vous publiez votre
premier roman piranha ce aux éditions
gallimard
consacré aux baby gang alors comme il ya
des enfants soldats il y a des enfants
mafieux c'est un sujet qui se remonte
que je suis trop vous trouvez face à une
histoire incroyable
d'enfants qui vivait entre 10 et 10
heures au
sommet d'une organisation mafieuse très
puissante je n'étais pas
évidente c'était pas des petits qu'il
est roux de petits pusher c'était
vraiment des chefs libre c'est
incroyable
cela a été possible parce que ses
enfants étaient géniaux
heureusement c'est un génie qu'était au
service du crime de la barbarie alors
piranha c'est un livre absolument
passionnant le livre raconte le parcours
de nicolas fiolet et de sa bande
d'adolescents sa part m ca son groupe
ils ont tous entre 14 et 18 ans il se
déplace son scooter ils font armés ils
sont fascinés par la violence et par le
crime il ne croit qu'aux pouvoir et à
l'argent ils ont plus peur de devoir
vivre comme leurs parents que de la mort
c'est la mort tu es nonais cube vista
comme lui on ne regarde plus la mort
comme un risque du métier comme un
déchet sida c'est une nécessité c'est la
suite de ce choix ces enfants veulent
mourir sous dos après avoir vu des
années pendant lesquelles ils ont tout
pris toi
je suis allé les voir les interviewer
bien évidemment les rescapés ils m'ont
demandé mais qu'est les tonnages j'ai
dit j'ai 38 ans
battue n'a aucune valeur qui compte
les personnes importantes mer à 20 ans
21 internat il m'a regardé avec c'est
incroyable cette attitude est une
nouvelle génération de caïds qui
remplace l'ancienne génération c'est la
génération des jeux vidéo la génération
des des réseaux sociaux on les appelle
les babys gangsters et leur monde et est
totalement binaire en fait c'est à dire
qu'elle est faible les forts les riches
que les pauvres les baiseurs et les
baisers kwassa kwassa la latika et réal
tard ccpo wheels et l'éthique si on peut
utiliser selon des organisations
mafieuses qui a deux choix que c est
faux tout au fond est ce que tu veux
être buzzer au baiser
l an dernier regard de rien c'est
peut-être la logique de notre temps
pas seulement dans les la criminalité
organisée sont hospitalisés fia c'est un
hymne quoi tu sais c'est un monde sans
pitié ce qui est intéressant
on vaut livres dont celui ci en
particulier c'est qu'en fait ça parle
des jeunes mathieu non celui là mais en
fait ça parle de la société moderne
c'est là où ça une dimension universelle
en fait votre livre cette jeunesse
décadente vous la raconter mais vous ne
la jugez pas
non parquet non je le jure ces personnes
ne sont pas des maîtres
et font pas partie d'une autre
civilisation qui concentrait nombre
racontent arena projet ambitieux que je
ne veux pas raconter n'est plus mon dell
monde travaillera plutôt raconter le
monde à travers naples alors roberto
vous vous êtes mis à dos la camorra et
les cartels mexicains les baby gangsters
et vous êtes mis à dos le nouveau
mussolini matteo salvini vous l'appelez
le ministre de la pègre vous parlez de
50 millions d'euros volés par le parti
de salvini la ligue ou dit un jour pas
si lointain les italiens comprendront ce
qu'est vraiment un traître à la patrie
ce qui est en train de se passer en
italie
est très intéressant je trouve pour la
france à l'étal il faut que la france
regarde les photos parce qu'elle va voir
son avenir matteo salvini
steiner chef mathieu salvini est en
train d'obtenir
ses élèves avec des arguments violent
considérant qu ils immigrent a t il même
si d'heure les immigrés
la cible numéro un de tous les maux
las potenza des populismes et qu'elle en
a besoin de la puissance du populisme
c'est qu'il n'a besoin de rien montré
sexuelle d'une arabia le populisme
reprend une colère qui est souvent
légitimes une déception qui est souvent
juste ma la stas postant des tibias
sommet
reprends tout ça pour des objectifs qui
ne sont pas du tout les bons objectifs
et
il y accéder un jour on arrêtait un
maire monsieur me muluka noah koussa a
été accusé d'avoir favorisé
l'immigration clandestine sans le
salvateur vite il n'a fait que sauver
des vies en réalité alors vous critiquez
tellement salvini que en juin dernier il
vous a menacé de vous retirer votre
protection policière magnéto serge ce
seront les institutions compétents qui
évalueront s'ils courent un risque réel
parce qu'il me semble qu'il passe
beaucoup de temps à l'étranger
mais ça me semble juste d'évaluer
comment l'argent des italiens défoncé
mais bon c'est le cadet de mes soucis
selon toi salvini je suis heureux de
vivre comme ça depuis onze ans depuis
plus de 11 ans gêné score depuis que
j'ai 26 ans mais toi tu penses menacé
m'intimider donc rester à l'écart ces
dernières années j'étais sous une
pression énorme la pression du clan des
casalesi la pression de la côte
mexicaine j'ai plus peur de continuer à
vivre comme ça que de mourir pour ça et
donc tu crois vraiment que je peux avoir
peur de toi et tes bouffon 20
bouffonne
belle alors vous dites salvini préfère
s'attaquer aux migrants pour pouvoir
mettre de côté les autres sujets
sensibles
il préfère qu'on le traite de raciste
que de voleurs et steven defour et tout
europe et kelly miller entière mais les
admirer sur les responsables de tous les
problèmes
ce n'est pas le cas ce n'est plus moi il
n'y a aucune invasion a plus autant de
cent mille personnes qui arrivent
et bien l'italie est un pays qui est en
train de perdre de plus en plus de
populations est en train de se vider
mais on peut adapter il faut choisir une
solution intermédiaire
le fait réfuter les migrants des wc
mourir dans la mer ou de laisser tout
simplement ouvertes les frontières la
positionne internet ridard et il vit ce
qu'elle est cette solution intermédiaire
c'est celle de donner des visas de
travail en europe on a refusé pour sa
politique de visas il faudrait un
nouveau prévoir ces visages pour
l'afrique
c'est une solution
pour
s'arrêter le désir de venir en europe
tout simplement avec des embarcations de
fortune en risquant sa propre vie en
italie à quelques années
sept cent mille migrants avaient été
reconnus
oui
et en plus c'est le gouvernement de la
ligue parce que servir parce que j'en
avais besoin alors pour vous les
italiens sont écrasés sous le poids
d'une politique qui se fait dans les
talk shows et sur les réseaux sociaux
vous parlez d'une politique provocatrice
qui parle aux citoyens dévastés par des
décennies de berlusconisme et d'anti
berlusconisme vous vous sentez un peu
seul
on porte que sur la butte ouates ge est
d'habitude au moins un petit peu et
la merde à kuching dit toujours que la
merde est utile et couettes utile pour
le sol riche et puis où l'émirat
difficile donc je pense que mes racines
vont être de plus en plus fécondes
[Musique]
alors je rappelle le titre de votre
nouveau livre donc est consacrée aux
baby gangsters ça s'appelle piranha
c'est publié chez gallimard alors ça
ferait un film formidable mais roberto
l'industrie du cinéma en glorifiant la
mafia n'est t'elle pas le principal
ennemi de votre combat
est intéressante de man c'est une
question très intéressante le trouvera
lamy a strategy à ma stratégie est la
suivante protège hermida la non pharma
et film au 16e je ne veux jamais vu
faire des séries ou des films
superficiel et raconta les mécanismes
c'est pour cela que j'essaie de raconter
tout ce qui est derrière comment ça
marche l'économie comment ça marche le
pouvoir et queen et qu'ils gardent aller
mais c'est donc ce qui regarde les
séries que j'ai écrite
savent jusqu'au bout que je raconte
irréalité qui est authentique
et molto de ce qu il
est très dangereux d'ailleurs de penser
que si je parle stordis du mal je suis
en train de diffuser le mal là roberto
il ya une dernière chose là j'y pense
c'est la question colombo
[Musique]
roberto si vous pouviez vous évader de
votre vie actuelle vous iriez où
mon poste devait gérer
quelque part où je pourrai recommencer à
zéro beauvais
ma présence ne mettrait pas en
difficulté ce qui même
j'ai gâché la vie de toutes les
personnes qui étaient autour de moi et
me neeman jeunes on pense comme la
droite je pense un endroit comme la
nouvelle zélande par exemple c'est le
web les corrections de ne rien rater de
l'ina l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux